quand j'étais plus jeune les adultes
autour de moi me disait souvent que je
m'excusais trop et que j'étais trop
gentille et que c'était assimilé à un
manque de confiance en moi il me
jugeaient trop sensible et me disaient
de m'endurcir car le manque de confiance
en soi dans une société où le culte de
la performance domine c'est un défaut
alors j'ai appris à cloisonner mes
émotions de mes compétences
j'ai appris à faire la part des choses
et plus tard beaucoup plus tard quand je
suis arrivé dans le milieu du
journalisme culturel où j'ai commencé
mon activité professionnelle
j'ai fait comme tout le monde dans tous
les métiers j'ai mis mon super masquer
mon plus beau masque de super héroïne
prête à déplacer des montagnes
imperturbable et toujours d'humeur égale
pourtant parfois je doute je suis
fatigué et je me pose beaucoup de
questions et quand j'en parle autour de
moi
du côté de mes proches on dit que de
toute façon je me fais pas suffisamment
confiance et que j'ai un travail de rêve
du côté de la direction on me dit que je
suis trop sensible et trop fragile et du
côté du réseau ces gens qui ne sont ni
vos amis votre famille mais avec
lesquels vous collaborez
professionnellement tout le temps du
côté du réseau
on s'envoie du courage à tour de bras
cros deadline courage gros projet
courage courage tient le coup mais sans
entrer dans le détail différentes formes
de souffrance existe dans les métiers
qu'on réserve qu'on exerce avec passion
on culpabilise parfois de ne plus
accueillir avec autant d'enthousiasmé et
d'envié toutes les tâches qui
s'accumulent et tout le flux
d'informations qui nous vient on a peur
d'être incompétent
on a peur d'être pas capables et on a
peur d'être pas fiable c'est très
difficile d'en parler en plus autour de
nous pourtant autour de nous on parle
beaucoup de souffrance au travail dans
mon secteur d'activité mais dans
beaucoup d'autres aussi stress anxiété
on entend tous ces termes au quotidien
assortie d'une injonction qui moi me
donne le tournis cette injonction au
développement personnel
il faut absolument se créer un fort
intérieur comme un rempart à l'extérieur
pour se protéger des autres être moins
stressé moins anxieux mais en se
détachant les conditions de travail et
le contexte économique ne sont pas mon
sujet mon propos mon propos il tourne
autour de la pudeur symbolique de nos
relations sociales qu'on pourrait
alléger
quand je recevais des lettres de
motivation je reconnaissais ces mêmes
mots que j'écrivais mois quelques années
plus tôt autonome déterminé volontaire
battant toujours disponible c'est vrai
qu'on m'avait dit très tôt que le milieu
professionnel que pour le milieu
professionnel il faut être armé et que
pour la vie en général il faut être bien
armé
les monts du sens et la métaphore est
pesé et elle sous-entend implicitement
que l'empathie ça reste du domaine
privée
alors moi dans mon cas dans mon
expérience personnelle j'ai tout donné
j'ai charbonnet sans compter sur 37
question mais je ne savais pas encore à
ce moment là que ma seule volonté de
bien faire ne suffirait pas à long terme
c'est à ce moment qu'intervient que
surgit dans ma vie la perte du de l'un
de mes plus proches amis michel bouche
de son petit surnom
et moi nous nous étions rencontrés dans
le cadre du travail de par nos activités
respectives et nous étions rapidement
devenus des amis très fusionnelle il
faisait partie de ceux qui sont
visionnaires parce qu'il regarde le
monde avec leur coeur ils avaient déjà
compris est anticipé que chercher la
reconnaissance dans lego nous isolerait
encore plus les uns des autres demain
quand il a disparu brusquement en juin
je n'ai rien compris je n'ai rien
compris à ce moment là je crois encore
que je vais pouvoir tout gérer continuer
à faire la part des choses et pourtant
au fond de moi je sens bien que cette
épreuve est que cette douleur inonde et
impacte tous les champs de ma vie alors
quand j'essaye de me raccrocher au
travail
je sens un malaise dans mes relations
sociales je sens que ma tristesse plein
comme un handicap au dessus de moi et je
sens que ce sujet du deuil de la mort
comme celui de la maladie ou de la
vieillesse
entre autres je sens que c'est tabou et
c'est tabou parce que ça renvoie à une
impuissance qui est incompatible avec
une société hyper active quand je suis
un soir je suis dans l'espace pro d'un
festival de musiques actuelles et je
converse avec des collaborateurs que je
connais depuis longtemps maintenant et
sur scène l'artiste entame un morceau
qui me rappelle un vif souvenir de
michel automatiquement spontanément une
petite larme coule sur ma joue en trente
secondes tout le monde avaient déguerpi
j'ai senti le malaise à ce moment là
et je ne reproche ici rien de personnel
à qui que ce soit j'ai juste à ce moment
précis fait le constat de cette pudeur
réflexe de cette pudeur de protection le
désarroi ça se vit chez soi sous sa
couette l'appel ce n'est pas bankable à
moins d'en faire un statut facebook ou
là j'aurais l' empathie immédiate et
éphémère du réseau social alors que
quand on se voit dans la vraie vie on
est très gênée et on n'arrive pas à se
reconnecter les uns aux autres dans ce
cas là les gens ont peur d'être voyeur
ou intrusif un peu paradoxal en fait on
n'a pas l'habitude d'exprimer nos
sentiments
on n'a pas l'habitude de comprendre et
d'accueillir les émotions les siennes
pas plus que celle des autres
au quotidien on me dit souvent ça va
aller c'est une mauvaise passe va passer
lâche rien et on entend souvent cette
histoire de cet homme ou de cette femme
qui se relève hyper rapidement il n'a
pas bronché il n'a pas pleuré
il s'est pas attardé sur sa peine ces
relevés direct ça force le respect mais
ça ne marche pas pour tout le monde
au bureau on me dit de surtout rien
lâcher et de continuer d'avancer et on
me dit prendre du repos et puis de
revenir en forme
d'autres me disent qu'il faut absolument
me changer les idées mais certaines
épreuves de la vie comme celle ci mais
d'autres s'ils nécessitent une
temporalité que nous ne savons plus nous
ne pouvons plus socialement et
collectivement nous permettre
on veut voir le résultat
mais sans le processus tout comme on
n'aime pas trop voir les ampoules aux
pieds des danseuses étoiles alors la
parole se libère aujourd'hui sur plein
de sujets dans plein de domaines et pour
beaucoup de gens c'est super mais il
faudrait vraiment l'accompagner d'une
empathie généralisée pour que
l'expression d'une souffrance quelle
qu'elle soit au travail ou ailleurs ne
soit plus jugé comme la manifestation
trivial d'une émotion mal géré c'est à
ce moment précis de mon chemin
peu sont arrivées dans ma vie des
personnes merveilleuses et visionnaire
elle aussi heureusement elles étaient
nombreuses et ces personnes là elles ont
réussi à dépasser ce cap de la
superficialité des relations mondaines
des relations mondaines festive déglingo
elles ont réussi à dépasser ça et à
dépasser leurs propres peurs parasites
qui sont de l'ordre de je la connais pas
tant que ça je fais pas je veux pas me
je veux pas me vous savez toutes ces
peurs là je veux pas me confronter c'est
trop lourd peut-être je sais pas toutes
ces peurs là ces personnes en question
ont réussi à les dépasser pour me
souffler dans les bronches de la
bienveillance et d'une indulgence sans
effusion mélodramatique par des gestes
très simples on n'est pas forcément
devenus amis pour la vie
tous ont continué à travailler ensemble
mais ensemble grâce à eux surtout on a
réussi à dépasser le stade des
apparences ils m'ont permis de
comprendre que parfois je pouvais
m'écrouler sans avoir honte et sans être
jetés brutalement dans le conte dans le
camp de ceux qui ne sont pas combatif ou
pas assez déterminés ils m'ont aidé
à traverser ce chemin compliqué
douloureux leur indulgence et leur
bienveillance c'est ce qui m'a fait le
plus avancé sur ce chemin est loin des
fantasmes de toute puissance et d'ego et
du je suis capable à tout prix parce qu
en fait oui on a besoin les uns des
autres et se serrer les coudes
maintenant au lieu de continuer et il
vaudrait mieux se serrer les coudes eux
maintenant lui de continuer à diriger
des remparts entre nous et si à la fin
de ces quelques mots vous avez le
sentiment qu'un geste une intention un
mot de votre part pourrait réchauffer un
choeur quelque part et bien même si vous
n'êtes pas intimes ou que la situation
n'est pas dramatique
envoyez le fait le demain sera peut-être
un petit peu plus doux et à cette toute
petite échelle
peut-être qu ensemble tous ensemble on
pourra devenir un petit peu meilleure
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]